the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
well ok I'm happy to be back and I'm
really happy about the project proposals
that are coming in
this is like ok this is a really a good
part of the course and so keep them
coming if and and I happy to give
whatever feedback I can on those
proposals and do make a start there
they're really good and if if some are
completed before the end of the semester
and we can give produce a chance offer
you a chance to report on them that's
that's good too so well done with those
proposals so while I'm today I'm jumping
to part six
so part six and part seven are
optimization which is the fundamental
algorithm that goes into deep learning
so we've got to start with optimization
everybody has to get that picture and
then part seven will be the structure of
CNN's convolutional neural nets and all
that all kinds of applications and so
can we start with optimization so first
could I like get the basic facts about
three terms of a Taylor series so that's
typical it's seldom that we would go up
to third derivatives in optimization so
that's the most useful approximation to
a function everybody recognizes it here
I'm thinking of f as just one function
and X as just one variable but but now I
really want to go to
more variables so what do I have to
change if f is a function of more
variables so now now I'm thinking of X
as well no let me see yeah I want n
variables here X is X 1 up to xn so what
it would just to get the words straight
so we can begin on optimization so what
will be the similar step so the function
f at X remember X is n variables okay
now what do I have Delta X so what
what's the point about Delta X now it's
a vector Delta X 1 to Delta X n and what
about the derivative of F it's a vector
to the derivative of F with respect to X
1 the derivative of F with respect X 2
and so on so what do I have what do I
have to change about that I now those
guys are vectors so it's their dot
product so it's Delta X transpose that
vector times this DF DX so what's the so
this now I'm replacing this by all the
derivatives and the it's the gradient so
the gradient of F at X is the
derivatives let's see it's essential to
get the notation straight here yeah so
it'll be the partial derivatives of the
function f so grad F is the partial
derivatives of F with respect to X 1
down to partial derivative the strike to
exam okay good that's the linear term
and now what's the quadratic term 1/2
now Delta X isn't a scalar anymore it's
a vector so I'm going to have Delta X
transpose and a Delta X and what goes in
between is the second derivatives but
I've got a function of n variables and
so what does this mmm so now I have a
matrix of second derivatives right and
I'll call it H this is the matrix of
second derivatives h JK is the second
derivative of F with respect to XJ and
XK and what's the name for this guy the
Hessian Hessian matrix how the Hessians
got into this picture I don't know the
only Hessians I know are the ones who
fought in the Revolutionary War for
somebody who which side were they on I
think maybe the wrong side the French
were on our side and yeah anyway Hessian
matrix and what what are the facts about
that matrix well the first fact is that
it's them and the key fact is it's
symmetric ok and again that's an
approximation so and everybody involved
recognizes that if we have a fun if n is
very large and we have a function of
many variables then we had n derivatives
to compute here and about 1/2 and
squared derivatives using the the half
comes from the symmetry but the key
point is the N squared variables
derivatives to compute there so
computing the gradient is feasible if n
is small or moderately large actually
you by using autumn
differentiation the key idea of back
propagation back prop you can get you
can do you can speed up the computation
of derivatives quite amazingly but still
for the size of deep learning problems
as that's that's how to reach okay so
that's the picture and then I will want
to solve use this to solve equations let
me there's a parallel picture for us
vector F so now this is a vector
function this is F 1 of X up to f of X
and X is X 1 to X n so I have n
functions of n variables and functions
of n variables well that's exactly what
I have in the gradient that's think of
these two is parallel the parallel being
s is corresponds to the gradient of F n
functions of n variables ok ok so now
maybe what I'm after here is to solve F
equals 0 so I'm going to think about the
the F at X plus Delta X so it starts
with f of X and then we have the
correction times the matrix of first
derivatives and what's the name for that
matrix of first derivatives
well if I'm just given n functions and I
yeah what am i what am i after here I'm
looking for the Jacobian so hair will go
the Jacobian J this is the Jacobian
named after Jacobi Jacobian matrix and
what are its entries J the JK entry is
the derivative of the Jayce function
with respect to the case very okay and
I'm stopping a first-order there okay so
these are those sort of like facts of
calculus facts of 1802 you could say
multivariable calculus that's the point
notice that we're we're doing just like
the first half of 1802 just different
differential calculus derivatives Taylor
series we're not doing multiple
integrals that's not part of our world
here okay so that's the background now I
want to look at optimization okay okay
so over here I want to optimize well
over here let me try to minimize f of X
and I'll be in the vector case here and
over here
I want to solve F equals zero and of
course that means that means F of one
equal to zero all the way along to F N
equals zero here I have n equations let
me start with that one and I'll start
with Newton's method Newton the best to
solve these n equations in n unknowns
okay so Newton which is often not
presented in 1802 that's a crime because
that's the that's the big application of
gradients in jacobians okay so I'm
trying to solve n equations in n
unknowns and so I want F at X plus Delta
X to be zero right so I want f of X plus
Delta X to be zero so so f of X plus
Delta X is I'm putting in a zero I'm
just copying that equation is f at where
I am X let's let me use K for the case
iteration so I'm at a point XK I want to
get to a point XK plus one and so I've 0
is f of X plus J at that point times
Delta X which is XK plus one minus XK
good that's Newton's method of course a
zero isn't quite true well zero will be
true for the for the if I'm constructing
XK plus one here I'm constructing XK
plus one okay so let me just rewrite
that knife and we've got Newton's method
so we're looking for this
change XK plus one minus XK I'll put it
on this side s plus XK so that's this
now I have to invert that and put it on
the other side of the equation so
that'll go with a minus this guy will be
inverted and F at XK that's Newton's
method natural let me just repeat that
you see where the XK plus 1 minus XK is
city right and I moved FX K to the other
side with a minus sign and then I
multiply through by J inverse so I got
that
so that's Newton's method for a system
of equations but over there I'm going to
write down Newton's method for
minimizing a function this is such basic
stuff that we have to begin here let me
even begin with a with a extremely
straightforward example of Newton's
method here suppose my function I
suppose I've only got one function
actually suppose I only have one
function so so I'm so suppose my
function is x squared minus 9 and I want
to solve f of X equals 0 I want to find
this square root of 9 okay so what what
is Newton's method for it we just should
see my point is just to see how Newton's
method is written and then rewrite it a
little bit so that we see there
convergence okay so so of course the
Jacobian is 2x so Newton's method says
that XK plus 1 I'm just going to copy
that
minus 1 over 2 XK
right that's the derivative times F at X
K which is XK squared minus 9 okay
we followed the formula we that this
determines XK plus 1 and let's let's
simplify it so here I have XK - that
looks like a half of XK so I think I
have a half of XK and then this times
this is 9 halves of one over X K is that
right half of XK from this stuff and
plus nine halves of one over X here ok
can I just like check that I know the
answer is three can I be sure that I get
the right answer 3 so this was that if
if XK was exactly three then of course I
expect XK plus 1 to stay at 3 so do what
does that happen so half of three and
nine halves of one serve what's that
half of three and nine halves of
one-third okay that's that's three
halves and three halves at six halves
and that's three okay okay so we've
checked that the method is consistent
which just means we kept the algebra
straight but then the really important
point about Newton's method is this is
to discover how fast it converges so now
let me dou XK plus one minus three so
now I'm looking at the error which is I
hope approaching zero
is it approaching zero how quickly is it
approaching zero these are the
fundamental questions of optimization so
I'm going to subtract three from both
sides
somehow okay from here I guess I'm gonna
subtract three can I just so I was just
checking that it was correct okay now so
XK plus one minus three I'm gonna
subtract three from both sides I'm gonna
subtract three there and then I hope
that that's that box is what goes down
here right subtracted three from both
sides so I'm looking at I'm hoping it
goes now hoping things go to zero okay
so what do I have there let me factor
out the 1 over X K so what do I have
then left one over X K so there's a 9
halves from there one over X K so I
really have 1/2 of X K squared because
I've divided by n X K and this minus 3 I
better put minus 3 X K cause I'm
dividing by X K I claim that that's okay
now I've got it
and let's see let me take out the 2 to
forget these twos and make that a 6 so I
have 1 over 2 X K times 9 plus X K
squared minus 6 anything good about that
we hope so week we hope that that is
something attractive so this is again
this is the error at step K plus 1 and
it's 1 over 2 X K times this thing in
brackets 9 plus X K squared minus 6x k
and we recognize that as X K minus 3
squared
XK squared minus six of them plus 9
that's XK minus 3 squared okay that was
the goal of course that's the goal that
shows why Newton's method is fantastic
if you can execute it if you can start
near enough notice that so that's that's
so how do I describe this this great
equation it says that the error is
squared at every step
squared at every step so if I'm
converging to a limit it will satisfy
that it'll be 3 or I guess minus 3 is
that possible
yeah minus 3 is another solution here so
we're so we've got two solutions the
Newton's method could converge to 3 am i
right it could converge to minus 3 so I
could I'd have a similar equation sort
of centered at minus 3 or what does it
always do one of those it could blow up
it could so that so those are there are
sort of regions of Attraction there are
all the starting points that approach 3
and the whole point of that equation is
with quadratic convergence the error
being squared at every step it seems in
on three then there's a whole all these
starting points that would would go to
minus 3 and then their their starting
points that would blow up so and and
those may be for this very simple
problem that the picture is not too
difficult to sort out those three
regions but if we had and this is
allowing for a vector
two equations or n equations then we're
in n variables and is really you get
beautiful pictures you get some some of
the type of pictures that gave gave rise
to these books on fractals the picture
books on fractals - for these basins of
attraction does the does the starting
point lead you to one of the solutions
or does it lead you to infinity here it
that would be interesting to just draw
it for this okay but the the essential
point is they're quadratic convergence
if it's close enough you see that it has
to be close if if X K is if X 0 is
pretty near 3 then this is about
one-sixth of that and there'll be a good
region of Attraction in this case okay
so that's that's Newton's method for
equations and now I want to do Newton's
method
I just want to convert all those words
over to Newton's method for optimization
so remember the these boards were
solving F equals 0
this board is minimizing capital F and
what's the connection between them well
of course when we this corresponds to
solving the gradient at a minimum if I'm
minimizing I'm finding a point where all
the first derivatives are zero so so
that'll be the match between these that
that this right F in this picture is the
small F in that picture
ok now I guess here I have and this is
sort of the heart of our applications to
deep learning we have very complicated
loss functions to minimize functions of
thousands or hundred
thousands of variable okay so that means
that we would like to use Newton's
method but often we can't let me so let
me so I need to to put down here two
methods one that doesn't involve those
high second derivatives and one a
Newton's that does so so so first so
first I'll write down a method that does
not involve so so method one and this
will be steepest descent and what is
that that says that XK plus one the new
X is the old X minus my steepest descent
means that I move in the steepest
direction which is the direction of the
gradient of F I move some distance and I
better have freedom to decide what that
distance should be so this is a step
size yes or in the language of deep
learning it's often called the learning
rate learning rate okay so is that that
so and it's natural to choose SK we're
going along do you see where what this
right hand side looks like I'm at a
point in n dimensions they were all it
were in n dimensions here we have
functions of n variables there's a
vector there's a direction to move down
the steepest slope of the of the graph
and here's a distance to move and we
will stop we'll have to get off this
step normally if we if we stay on it a
little sway it'll swing back it'll take
us off to infinity
wait the the you would like to choose SK
so that you minimize capital F you take
the point on this line so this is I'm
this is a line in our in a direction in
RN and for all the points on that line
in that direction F has some value and
what you expect is that initially
because you chose it sensibly the value
of F will drop but then at a certain
point it'll it'll turn turn back on you
and increase so that would be the
natural stopping point and that would I
would call that an exact line search so
exact line search would be exact line
search is the best sense of course that
would take time to to compute and you
probably in deep learning that's time
you can't afford so you fix the learning
rate s maybe you choose point o1 to be
pretty safe okay so that's method one
steepest descent now a method two will
be Newton's method so now we have XK
plus one my two XK minus something times
Delta F
and now I'm going to do the right thing
I'm gonna live right here and the right
thing is the Hessian the second
derivative that's what this is this was
cheap we just took the direction and and
went along it now we're getting really
the right direction by using the second
derivative so that's H inverse okay and
what I've done is to is to set that to
zero so that would be do you see thats
Newton's method
it's totally parallel to this guy
actually I'm really happy to have these
two on the board parallel to each other
because you have to kind of keep
straight are you solving equations or
are you minimizing functions and you're
using different letters in the two
problems but now you see how they match
the Jacobian of so so again the matches
think of F as the gradient of F that's
that's the way you should think of it so
the Jacobian for of the gradient is the
Hessian the Jacobian of the gradient is
the Hessian and that makes sense because
we take the first derivative of the
first derivative is the second
derivative only we're doing matrix y so
that's so the Jacobian of the gradient
we're doing a vector matrix sentence
instead of a scalar sentence the
Jacobian of the gradient is a Hessian
yep right okay so that's what I wanted
to start with just to get those basic
facts down and so the basic facts were
the were the three term Taylor series
and then the basic algorithms followed
naturally from it by setting the
FF at the new point to zero if that's
what you were solving or by assume he
had right good good good good okay now
what now we have to think about solving
these problems
studying do they converge what rate do
they converge well that's the rate of
convergence is like what I why I took
this separated off this example so the
convergence rate for Newton's method
will be quadratic the error gets squared
and of course that means super fast
convergence if you start close enough
the rate of convergence for a steepest
descent is of course not you're not
squaring errors here because you're
you're just taking some number instead
of the inverse of the correct matrix so
you you can't expect SuperSpeed so a
linear rate of convergence would be
right you expect that the error to you
would like to know that the error is
multiplied by said every step by some
constant below one that would be a
linear rate where compared to be
multiplied by being squared at every
step and so this will be our our basic
this is the basic formula for for
large-scale for really large-scale
problems and there are methods of course
people are going to come up with methods
that they're sort of a cheap Newton's
method Levenberg Marquardt and it's in
the notes at the end of this section at
the end of the six point for that we'll
get to
so Levenberg Marquardt is a sort of
cheap man's Newton's Newton's method it
does not compute to Hessian but it can
but it says okay I owe i from the
gradient I can see a
sort of one term in the Hesse you know
so it grabs that term but it's not fully
fully second-order okay so now we're now
we have to think about problems and I
guess the whole the the message here is
and our starting point has to be
convexity convexity is the key word for
this for these for these problems for
the function that we want to minimize if
that's a convex function well first of
all the convex function is likely to
have one minimum and the picture that's
in our mind of steepest descent this
picture of a bowl a bowl is the graph of
a convex function so that so I'm turning
to convexity now I'll leave that board
there because that's pretty crucial and
speak about the idea of convexity convex
function convex set so let's call the
function f of X and typical convex set
will be i'll call it k okay so we just
want to remember what does that word can
convex mean and how do you know if you
have a convex function or a convex set
okay let me start with convex set so
it's a because here's my general problem
my convex minimization which you hope to
have an in many applications you do have
so you minimize a convex function for
points in a convex set so that's like
the ideal situation that's the ideal
situation okay get something
inside something powerful convexity the
function is convex and so let me draw
our convex function with the graph
ok so I'll draw our convex function say
Bowl so that's a graph of f of X and
then so here are the X's with X 1 and X
2 in the base and the graph of f of X 1
X 2 up here okay actually I'm over there
I should be calling this function f I
think is that right yeah little F would
be there graining of this guy yeah I
think so okay so so what now I'm
minimizing over X in over certain X's
not all X's I might be minimizing for
example K might be the set where ax
equals B K might be in that case a
substrate or a shifted subspace when I
said subspace but then 1806 is reminding
me in my mind that I only have a
subspace when V is 0 but I have a you
know the word for a subspace that sort
of moved over a fine so I'll just put
that word down a bunch of words to learn
for this topic but okay so it's a it's
like a plane but not necessarily through
the origin if B is 0 it doesn't go
through if B is not ok anyway or I have
some other convex set let me just put
this
like said K in the base and did I make
it convex I think pretty good luckily I
did so now what well the convex sets the
the constraint so this is the constraint
set constraint is that X must be X is in
the set K okay and I drew it as a convex
blob here was an example where it's a
flat not a blob but a flat flat plane
but what does let me come back to what
does convex mean what what's a convex
set
yeah let's we have to do that should
have done that before
in the in the notes I had the fun of
figuring out if I took two if I took a
triangle is that a convex set let's just
be sure so what's a convex set that is a
convex set because if I take any two
points in the set and draw the line
between them it stays in this set so
that's convexity any edge line from x1
to x2 stays in in the set okay good so
here's my little exercise to myself what
if I took the union of two triangles all
I want to get you to do is this sort of
thing visualize convex and not convex
possibilities suppose I have two one
triangle even if it was obtuse that's
still convex right
no problem but now what if I put those
two triangles together take their union
well if I take them sitting with a big
gap between like I've lost I mean I've
never had a chance that way because if I
took one of my if it was the union of
these two well you know what I'm gonna
say if I took that point in that point
of course it goes outside stupid all
right what about a but what if the
triangles what if what if that triangle
that lower triangle kind of overlaps the
upper triangle is that a convex set
you're everybody's right saying no why
how do I see that the union of those two
triangles is not a convex set guys you
tell me where to pick two points where
the line goes out well I take one from
that corner and one from that corner and
the line between them went outside
so you Union is usually not convex well
if I think of the union of two sets my
mind actually automatically goes to the
the other corresponding possibility
which is the intersection of the two
sets so if I take the intersection of
the two sets now what's the deal with
that
what was the when I had two triangles
two separated triangles what what can we
say about the intersection of those two
triangles it's empty so shall we regard
the empty set as a convex set yes isn't
it it's vacuous so it hasn't got any
problems right
okay but now is the intersection is
always convex if I'm assuming the two
sets that we start with are now that's
an important fact that the intersection
of convex sets let's just draw a picture
that shows an example so what's the
intersection just this part and it's
convex okay can you give me a little
proof that the intersection is convex so
I take two points in the intersection
let me start the proof to test if
something's convex how do you test it
you take two points in the set in the
intersection and you want to show that
the line between them is in the
intersection okay why is that so take
two points take x1 in the intersection
of we've got two sets here and that's
the symbol for intersection and we've
got another point in the intersection
and now we want to look at the line
between them the line from x1 to x2
what's the deal with that one is that
fully in x1 in k1
why is it fully in k1 this we took two
points in the intersection I'm looking
at the line between them and I'm asking
is it in the first set k1 and the answer
is yes
because those points were in k1 and k1
is convex and is that line between them
in k2 yes same reason the X the two
endpoints were in k2 so the line between
them is in k tube so the intersection of
convex sets is always convex the
intersection of convex
it's good so you'll see in the notes
these possibilities with two triangles
there's sometimes you can you can take
the Union but not very often
okay now what's what's the next thing I
have to do convex functions we got
convex sets what are convex functions
then we're good right because this is
our this is our prototype of a problem
and I now want to know what it means to
be for that F to be a confident I'm
sorry I now know what it means for the
said K to be convex set but now I have
to look at the other often more
important part of the problem what's the
function I'm minimizing and I'm looking
for functions with this kind of a
picture okay
the coolest way is to connect the
definition of a convex function to the
definition of a convex set this is
really the nicest way it's a little
quick it just switches by you but tell
me do you see a convex set in that
picture you see a convex set in that
picture that's the picture of a graph of
a convex function it's a picture of a
bowl is are the points on that surface
is that a convex set no certainly not
no but where is a convex set to be found
here in that picture yes yes the points
on and above the bowl the in inside the
bowl we could say these points so convex
function me yes a functions convex when
the points on and above the graph
our our convex set yeah this is you
could say okay math my mathematicians
are just being lazy having got one
definition straight for a convex said
now they're just using that to give an
easy definition of a convex function
actually it's quite useful for functions
that could maybe equal infinity sort of
general generalized functions but it's
not the quickest way to tell if the
function is convex it's not our usual
test for convex function so now I want
to give such a test okay so now I
definition of convex function smooth
yeah yeah the the this fact don't rush
in Russia off away from it from the from
the definition of a convex function as
having a convex set above its graph
there's a really official French name
for that said above the graph is the
epigraph okay because why do I come back
to that for a minute because I would
like to think about two functions F 1
and F 2 out of two functions I can
always create the minimum or the maximum
so I suppose I have two convex functions
convex functions F 1 and F 2
okay then I could choose the minimum I
could choose my new function shall i
call it little m for minimum M of X is
the minimum of f1 and f2 and I could
choose a maximum function which would be
the maximum of f1 of X and f2 of X at
the same point X if I it's just a
natural thing okay I have two functions
I've got a bowl and I've got another
bowl and suppose they're both convex so
I'm just stretching you the thing here
if I've got I've got the graphs of two
convex functions and I would like to
consider the minimum of those two
functions and also the maximum of those
two functions I believe you know life is
good one of these will be convex and the
other won't and can you identify which
one is convex and which one is not
convex what about the minimum is that a
convex function so just look at the
graph what does the minimum look like
the minimum is this guy until they meet
somehow on some surface and then this
guy is that convex we have like one
minute to answer that question
absolutely no it's got this bad kink in
it what about the maximum of the two
functions so the maximum is the one that
it's above all the all the points that
are or things that are above or on on
the there there's the there's the
maximum function that was the minimum
function it had a kink the maximum
function is like that and it is convex
so maximum yes
minimum know and we could max if we
could have a maximum of 1500 functions
if the 1500 functions are all convex the
maximum will be because it's the part
way above everybody everybody's graph
and that would be the graph of the
maximum okay good
and now finally let me just say how do
you know whether a function is convex
how to test out of Chester
okay so let me take just a function of
one variable what's what's the test you
learn in calculus freshman calculus
actually just show that this is a convex
function what's what's the test for that
second derivative should be positive or
possibly zero so second derivative
greater equals zero everywhere
that's this convex okay final question
suppose F is a vector so this is a
vector and so I have n functions of n
variable no I don't have one
sorry I've got one function but I'm in n
variables so so this was just one that
what's the test for convexity yes so it
would be passed for example by x1
squared plus x2 squared would it be
passed by so here would be the question
would it be passed by X transpose some
symmetric matrix F that would be a
quadratic the pure quadratic would it be
convex
what would be the test it's got I'm
looking for an n-dimensional equivalent
of positive second derivative the
n-dimensional equivalent of positive
second derivative is convexity and we
want it we have to recognize what's the
test so I could apply it to this
function or I could apply it to any
function of n variables okay what's the
test here here I have a matrix instead
of a number so what's what's a good
requirement going to be x out yeah
positive definite or semi definite or
semi definite just as here yeah so the
test is positive semi definite yes yes
and here the Hessian is actually that is
because the second derivatives will
produce output 1/2 in there the second
derivatives will produce s equal the
Hessian H so this here the S so positive
semi definite Hessian in general second
derivative matrix for for a quadratic
okay so so those it's convex problems
that where we're going to get farther
with we run into no saddle points we run
into no local minimum once we found the
minimum it's the global minimum these
are the good problems okay again happy
to see you today and I look forward to
Wednesday